[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de vivre que nous
consacrons aujourd'hui à une hauteur
historienne d'origine versaillaise qui
sort le roman de rosa bonheur que voici
et j'accueille donc patricia bouchon ou
des chats bonjour bonjour véronique
ithurbide merci de m'accueillir merci
d'être venus jusque là c'est un grand
plaisir c'est pas la première fois qu'on
se rencontre car vous êtes comme je les
dis historienne et auteure vous avez
commis déjà plusieurs biographies
dont celle avait dont on avait parlé
nous toutes les deux à savoir la
biographie de notre ouïe pour commencer
nous rendrait le notre héros de suite
charles perrault voilà et alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes ici pour vous avez
changé de siècle oui on est ou 19e oui
et vous allez nous parler d'échangés de
genre échange de jean-louis voilà vous
parlez d'une femme est donc cette
fameuse rosa bonheur est une artiste
peintre animalière des plus célèbres de
son siècle et encore aujourd'hui à
l'heure actuelle alors on va revenir un
tout petit peu en arrière comment vous
est venue cette idée de vous attaquer si
je puis dire au roman de rosa bonheur à
l'heure
le hasard fait bien les choses de la
même manière qu'à un moment donné moi
qui était plongée dans le 18e j'ai été
déporté vers le dix septième par une
rencontre qui avait été celle avec
béatrix saule l'époque directrice et
château de versailles de la même manière
c'est une autre rencontre celle ci avec
catherine roux donc la présidente du
château et propriétaire du château de
rosa bonheur qui un jour m'a fait venir
elle venait d'acheter racheter 7 château
de rosa bonheur que ces cours qui se
trouve à thomery donc en lisière de
forêt de fontainebleau pas très loin
donc d'ici et qui m'a dit m'a dit est ce
que vous écririez un roman sur rosa
bonheur et donc rosa bonheur pour moi
c'était à la fois une peintre j'ai des
attaches à bordeaux il y avait jamais il
y avait plein de points communs qui
faisaient que pourquoi pas mais mais il
fallait peut replonger dans le 19ème ce
qui me renvoyaient la montansier sur wii
on avait beaucoup parlé et puis c'était
revenir au roman aussi j'avais déjà
écrit deux romans dans l'arène elle
absente et et je lis que je ne sais pas
si j'écris un roman mais vous êtes en
train de sauver votre château moi je
vais vous aider à sauver le parc est
déjà alors l'avait quelque chose
incroyable là dedans ça veut dire
plonger sans l'un dans les sources des
sources nouvelles qui étaient là-bas et
au fur et à mesure de cette restauration
en plongeant les mains dans la terre est
bien gérée dans ses archives je suis
j'ai plongé en fait dans l'histoire de
rosas en découvrant mille et une choses
qui n'avaient jamais été racontée et un
siècle que j'ai eu envie de faire
revivre et un personnage absolument
extraordinaire personnage de femme moi
j'aime les personnages de femmes il ya
eu la montansier la planète et rosa
bonheur j'ai envie j'ai eu envie de la
dépoussiérer
delà de la remettre dans son siècle est
certes on en a fait une icône du
féminisme c'est une icône du féminisme
mais pour certainement des raisons plus
complexe et plus riche qu'on ne l'a dit
jusqu'à présent oui c'est ce qu'on
découvre en détail on est à vous
raconter sa vie alors vous avez vous
raconter aussi qu'elle allait céder
mémoire que vous avez retrouvé dans le
grenier de ce fameux château tout est
restée intacte et dans ses mémoires
qu'elle a dicté à une de ces derniers un
ami vous nous dites attention parce que
des mémoires d'une personne âgée
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit on les adore
alors les mémoires
ont été publiés par sa dernière amy est
bien quand on voit des mémoires alors je
les ai pas retrouvé dans le grenier
pardon parce que non mais c'est ce qui
me plaisait la propriétaire a eu le
courage de les faire réimprimer à le fac
similé de l'original avec ses 500
illustrations donc c'est vraiment un
exemplaire magnifique on peut se
procurer en allant sur le site du
château rosa bonheur aux éditions de
l'atelier et
des mémoires d'une personne qui raconte
sa vie à
la ville ouais elle vient déjà on dit
attention parce que on on tisse une
histoire anti sa propre histoire il
laisse second volet c'est ça cette
première pour le premier cas et le et le
second c'est le fait que ça soit écrit
par une autre femme qui est une
américaine elle est donc même si elle
parlait le français et c est là l as est
là il a encore un regard qu'il faut
analyser les brutes pincettes et quand
on lit ses mémoires quand on lui dit
rien et qu'on connaît un peu cette
époque là on voit qu'il ya des il ya
quelques erreurs déjà sur le pan
d'histoire générale donc elles viennent
certainement de la part d'anne à mai
mais du coup on se dit tiens tiens tiens
ce qui est raconté on le lit avec avec
une grande avec à la fois une grande
prudence et en même temps en même temps
il faut le comparer je vais vous donner
un exemple tout bête on parle par
exemple beaucoup de rosa bonheur son
choix du célibat qu elle ne voulait pas
d'homme et s'est accéléré et
effectivement dans les mémoires qu'elle
laisse à anna elle dit très clairement
jamais je ne me suis mariée c'est une
promesse qu'elle a fait sur la tombe de
sa mère
je ne m est de toute façon une vie
d'artiste
d'épousé et de mère de famille ça n'est
pas compatible d'accord en revanche si
vous lisez les mémoires d'une de ses
amies plus jeune virginie de mon breton
qui est elle aussi une grande figure du
féminisme d'une famille donc de
d'artistes et qu'ils allaient céder les
murs très intéressant notamment sur rosa
rosa lui dit
comme je vous envie d'avoir réussi à
être à la fois
artiste mères et épouses et mères donc
vous voyez c'est rien et n'est binaire
enfin dans l'histoire d'un personnage et
c'est ça qui est intéressant est donc en
fait quand on plonge dans un personnage
il faut le remettre dans son contexte
expurgé un peu nos propres clichés du
21e siècle précis mais la bonne argana
peu de regarder un peu ce qui se passe
dans ce personnage qui qui est d'une
richesse absolument aller les
revêtements hors du commun pour l'époque
oui franchement elle et elle démarre sa
vie d'une façon incroyable parce que
très jeune elle a déjà la chance d'être
prise dans une école de garçons enfin
d'aller à l'école avec ses frères ce qui
n'était pas du tout
prévu et habituel donc déjà après est là
elle adore sa mère et ses parents ont
des idées très très moderne pour
l'époque absolument qui sont pour la
libération de la femme expliquez-moi
comment
en quelques mots donc pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas le personnage parce
qu'on on dit allez allez célèbre oui
c'était une star de son temps mais qui
quand même tombé un peu dans les
oubliettes de l'histoire oui rosa gones
nature et donc quand on parle de rosa
bonheur encore de nos jours heureusement
qu'il ya ce bicentenaire qui permet de
san mames le 16 mars il va toute l'année
qui va être célébrée avec l'exposition
qui va permettre de remettre en lumière
ce personnage son oeuvre est qui et qui
est passionnant heures qui devrait déjà
défilé peut être bon vouloir ou vers des
missions voilà en tous les cas ce
personnage est un personnage
très riche et ce qui est né en 1822 à
bordeaux vont qu'à l'âge de 7 ans arrive
à paris et qui va connaître ce pari avec
tous ces grands changements elle arrive
à paris en diligence tirés par des
percherons
elle voyagera ensuite d'abord en
diligence et très vite il va y avoir le
train donc on va connaître à connaître
la révolution m industrielle elle va
connaître les pandémies elle va
connaître la guerre les révolutions les
guerres extérieures il va connaître
surtout la situation d'une jeune fille
absolument en quelque sorte privilégiées
elle grandit dans une extrême pauvreté
financière de ses parents est d'ailleurs
sa mère va mourir de
d'épuisement à essayer de nourrir sa
famille puisqu'elle a un père artiste
qui croient dans les grandes idées il en
avait assez des rats très absent mais sa
grande chance et effectivement comme
vous l'avez dit très justement c'est
elle va grandir dans un milieu avec des
idées très avancé voit le père comme la
mère croit en l'égalité entre eux là
l'homme et la femme la femme est l'égalé
de l'homme donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement belley et comme vous
l'avez dit elle a la chance en arrivant
à paris d'être prises avec ses frères
dans une école pour moi pour garder vos
abonnés c'est un personnage formidable
parce que son énergie cette source cette
phrase qui a été choisi comme titre pour
le roman j'ai l'énergie d'une lionne
dans un corps d'oiseau cette phrase elle
l'écrit à son frère elle à 77 ans et
quelques mois avant de mourir
cette énergie c'est une énergie qu'elle
qui a été in et puis c'est un tout au
long de sa vie à partir de 11 ans elle a
commencé à travailler à 14 ans apportait
de la joan sa vie oui elles nourrissent
à face était complètement fou toute sa
vie elle l'a fait j'ai l'impression
qu'elle est apparemment je vous coupe
allen vicky qui à coup elle hasard
heureux elle s'est attrapé la chance un
coup à un obstacle terrible elle
rebondit et finalement elle a réussi à
se créer une vie hors du commun en étant
vraiment peintre professionnel est
finalement l on a besoin qu'elle ne
choquait pas plus que ça parce que oui à
la dent vous allez me contre aux
finances a été nommé reçus par alors
le vide à bord d'abord il faut savoir
que au 19e siècle à condition de la
femme est quand même une condition qui
est extrêmement difficile lewis et
nassara de droit pas le droit pas de
droits juridiques n'ont pas droit de
vote pour les artistes pas le droit de
faire l'école des beaux-arts évidemment
on n'entre pas dans une académie ni quoi
que ce soit dans ses rets mais que
l'ugtt et donc c'est une lutte elle a la
chance d'avoir un père peintre qui est
un peintre un peintre reconnu de cinq
ans qui va la forme et elle est formée
avec les meilleurs artistes au louvre et
elle va acquérir une reconnaissance par
son travail qui va en faire l'égal de
l'homme quand on va voir ses tableaux
avec d'abord des qui vont devenir de
plus en plus important en corée a mené
une vie elle arrive à voir des formats
de plus en plus en plus en plus grands
qui vont être un véritable manifeste
elle va se poser en tant que
portraitiste mais portraitiste des
animés mais voilà après this animalière
et elle le fait avec un
réalisme qui est qui est absolument
extraordinaire parce que pour elle c'est
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas étonnant qu'elle
va être très vite attirée par la
photographie elle très vite voilà
ateliers
marché aux chevaux donc et une très
grande
voilà là donc ça c'est ça c'est une des
versions du budget vert du rouge
attribué à guillaume et qui permet de
donner une idée exacte oeuvre est là
elle a quand même marqué un
moment de sa carrière parce que c'est là
ah bah si le tableau à voyager elle a
quand même rencontré un agent qui a été
la tête de l'eau pour elle voilà
seulement qui a emporté son tableau
comme une guest star alors mieux
travailler plus rosa il fait faire un
portrait de rosa bonheur qui est
trimballé avait et il y fait écrire une
biographie ces voix-là illusions dès
lors en angleterre et en écosse qui va
se poursuivre aux états unis et qui va
faire de rosa bonne une star aux états
unis au point que en vendre à l'époque
il y avait une espèce de poupée barbie à
l'effigié de rose à l'honneur parce que
ben rosa bonheur elle fascine elle elle
doit faire le plein par l accord sur un
pantalon donc 1 à 1 à 5 sur paris qui
porte le pantalon il fallait un permis
de travestissement fondée sur un
certificat médical pour un certain
nombre de raisons elle contrairement à
george sand elle dit bien moi pour moi
on de la femme est l'égal de l'homme
n'ont pas reprenant un nom masculin non
pas en portant le pantalon mais en étant
soi-même et en s'imposant par ces les
qualités son propre travail et donc
c'est sa peinture on parle sociaux
chaussée 5 mètres 40 sur 2 mètres 50
elle mesure 1 mètre 50 donc c'est un
manifeste de puissance et xsara qui est
incroyable l'impératrice eugénie va pas
s'y tromper elle c'était une grande
féministe c'est elle qui va la décorer
elle va être une des premières artistes
récompensés la légion
c'est que cette fille incroyable et
palpitante vraiment on est on est pris
par ce roman au rentre-dedans veut
savoir ce qui va se passer on oublie un
peu le côté biographie parce que c'est
une vraie histoire dingue mais réelle et
je trouve ça donne beaucoup d'espoir sur
cette femme qui malgré tous les
obstacles parce que je sais qu'elle en a
eu donc là on ne peut pas tout raconter
parce que mahler seller l'émission se
termine mais ça donne de l'espoir d'être
finalement elle s'est bien débrouillé
d'une façon même magistral avec son
talent et surtout cheyrou sa diplomatie
et sa façon de s'imposer sans heurter
trop les gens enfin ça il faut lire le
livre pour le comprendre elle se
débrouille drôlement bien quand même
voilà mais l on peut voir on verra des
bulles en automne 22 musée d'orsay alors
rétrospective est l'année aux mesures
d'assiette seconde ans la maintenance
jour depuis les airs au château rosa
bonheur exposition temporaire de ces
plaques il faut y aller est voilà relais
il y en a deux et raconte une histoire à
bordeaux musée des beaux-arts de
bordeaux à partir de mai et bien sûr
d'orsay musée d'orsay à partir du mois
d'octobre donc une grande année
rosa-bonheur grande année vaut à bonheur
écouter un grand merci patricia bouche
de deschamps est vraiment cinéma jouant
laquelle les voir avant d'aller au musée
d'orsay ou même à thomery c'est bien de
lire le livre voilà merci à très vite à
très bientôt au revoir merci
[Musique]